basta basta
mein absolutes lieblings
grundnahrungsmittel ich meine es gibt
kartoffeln getreide es gibt pasta mein
job ich liebe pasta basta ist einfach
ein traum ist es so einfach kann so
schnelle gerichte damit kochen und es
ist eigentlich immer lecker aber wie
lecker kann passt da sein diese frage
haben wir uns heute gestellt und sind
deshalb auf tripadvisor gegangen haben
die beste pasta war in köln raus gewesen
nicht die beste passabel und den besten
standort passt dagegen von allen
restaurants die pasta serviert nummer
eins von allen restaurants in köln
nummer drei caruso passt aber
hier ist das gute stück platz 3 von 1896
restaurants das ist krass und wir gucken
als allererstes in die bewertung wir
kommen ja gerade vom restaurantbesuch
und dementsprechend ist es für uns
doppelt spannend zu lesen aber wir
wollten uns natürlich nicht spoilern
deshalb machen wir das jetzt erst
gastgeber mit leidenschaft zu einem
gelungenen restaurantbesuch gehört nicht
nur eine hervorragende küche sondern
auch ein rundum gelungener service wer
hat von meinem teller hier gegessen
reine show ok drei von fünf punkten
leider wurden unsere hohen erwartungen
nicht erfüllt also hohe erwartungen ist
ja klar eine platz 3 von allen und
bestes pastor restaurant kann ich
nachvollziehen den kommentar denn wir
sehen und anfassen kann beste pasta die
man bekommen kann einfach klasse
einzigartig tipptopp immer wieder gern
tolles essen faire preise
leute ihr merkt es sind vorwiegend
wirklich sehr sehr gute kommentare und
es war sehr schlimm für mich aber ich
musste es einfach austesten ich will
wirklich so unnormal gespannt weil ich
kenne einige gute passaus trotzdem könnt
den kannte ich noch gar nicht ich glaube
uns erwartet was leckeres aber auch süß
die beste in köln ist sehen
[Musik]
erste was ich unnormal liebe es den 10
das ist wirklich winzig das heißt
eigentlich immer nur was gutes ich freue
mich richtig so ein schöner tag draußen
und den schönen tag in schöne passt dann
nur noch besser machen sie kann ihn zum
besten halt machen und alles ist
stilecht einmal die fische richtig
gericht sich selbst geburt
mit gerd koslowski wir haben drei bis
fünf gänge man fand von der karte wählen
und was die kosten eines
in rot mit was genau wissen wir nicht
mehr gerade ich hab so unnormal hohe
erwarten wir haben dieses brot hier
bekommen und ich will und ich hoffe dass
es irgendwie besonders hat mir mal was
auch immer das hier ist ein mal rein
dürfen und
wie motiviert man sich ja nichts anderes
zu rosmarin ist wasser in den super fi
außen knusprig pinsel
forscher aber deutlich niedriger
rote beete oder
geben zwischen brutto- seien aber so süß
mit
drei gänge
sehen wir aber sich der vorspeisen
weinbau stützkorsett rotbarsch
jetzt soll ausgerechnet ich zumindest
glaube rausgehen werde ob du zurück bist
ja ich bin auf den geschmack gekommen ok
dann passt dann der hauptgang darauf uns
natürlich am meisten an geröstete
blumenkohl cappellacci keine arm wasser
sein sollten auch cappellacci nicht
wiederholen aber packen
so dünn blicken können dann schoss das
braten conti pinienkerne der papa del
ist okay du findest hier keine spaghetti
bolognese du dich hier kann nichts es
gibt viel pasta gerichte wir angeblich
besten kaster bei köln und nichts davon
ist was das man kennt das ist spannend
auf jeden fall und ich habe schluss ich
gehe die kehre ich werde auch chip
unternehmen auch bei der oktopus und
weißt du was ich hier lieber du sagst
mit dem ich liebe wirklich diese private
geht das viel brot gekommen ist schon
wird der pastor habe ich voll gut zu den
zum gericht so ist es auf jeden fall
ordentlich an gerät bin gespannt wer vom
bisher das thema wie gesagt letztes hat
es den überraschend
ok er hat ein bisschen mehr bis er
letztlich aber die
unfassbaren grill der holzkohle gegrillt
das schmeckt so süß schmeckt kebab land
tut even level holzkohle oder kulturgut
wein oliven immer super lecker text
bensheim wird jetzt direkt wieder ab mit
allen texturen es gibt neues badezimmer
wo man das ding ist wir waren ja nicht
darauf eingestellt und dieser teller
sieht schon sehr sehr hübsch aus wir
sind nämlich bei frank prosieben wo wir
zwei nieren für verkaufen
ich habe den laden gesehen so ne online
und dachte mir so okay wir gehen ihm
passt aber das ist die viel mehr
war ich probier's mal alles zusammen
es macht einfach nur mal bock auf mehr
das führe ich habe genau das ist auch
die funktion
weiß krass findet man vergisst dass man
ja barroso war auch das ist ja keine
schlechte gegen aber man würde einfach
nicht dieses restaurant hier erwarten
und man vergisst dass bolt weiß was das
aber auch zeit gutem essen bewerben sich
[Applaus]
also mann aus ich habe mir nicht
[Musik]
glaubt man auf jeden fall aber
interessante kreationen so von der vom
teller von plating aber trotzdem wir
haben hier auch nackte pasta und ich
glaube das ist er flexibel wie machen
wir uns selbst und ich habe es ist grün
das kommt mir bekannt worden im kongo
von
das gesetz gibt so wollen wir mal
probiert es sind acht
lassen dass man zum stern ich sind so
größere sternen die portionen sind dass
es gibt sehr intensiv nehmen hier noch
schon so gesattelt und etwas von um den
getrockneten tomaten mit
eingespannt werden
kranke wo ich die eigene passt die
eigentliche passt natürlich etwas
besonderes unsichtbar in den ersten
kontakt mit dem 10 si super aber es ist
was dann genau so erkennt dass man noch
so passen kaum hat das ist mir jetzt so
wie eigentlich kennt man das so nicht
immer ist es immer entweder oder kauen
aber so können wir heute darauf eingehen
wie krass dieses gefühl und es entsteht
ja du kommst nicht klar das ist wieder
dieses nicht klarkommen weil so viel
passiert aber du bist mittlerweile
aber ist ja auch da überlegen wir was
haben wir jetzt auch wir haben berater
die satin getrocknete tomaten
pinienkerne das ist das krasse von
getrockneten und tabellen sind eine so
extreme so süß salzig und einfach nur so
pure sich greifen und dann diese berater
die das wieder neutralisiert diese
devise
pinienkernen denn so slightly
dieser piening mehr so im hintergrund
sich die ganze zeit versteckt aber
trotzdem da ist von dem
fast alle von dem bestand herrn pastor
ist das wahrscheinlich die krasseste die
ich je hatte wir haben hier eine
italienerin mit am tisch ex-freundin und
siehst er hat das will was heißen also
wir sind alle begeistert von diesem
häuserreihen form passt an diese
komposition ist super lecker aber ich
liebe halt auch um fahrspaß
traditionelle pasta gerichte und es ist
nicht die beste ist einfach mal ist
übelst die blauen jeanshose
für mich nicht die kasse
und alles in allem eine krasse erfahrung
ich habe gerade mal die bestandteil
unserer pastoral googelt und das kommt
kein bild von dieser passt nicht
ziemlich was haben die nämlich auch
gerade erklärt die gucken was sie
regional passieren können und dann
entwickeln die kreative gerichtet das
heißt das was ich gerade gesagt habe
sondern bolognese das gibt es gar nichts
außer es gibt genau zu dem zeitraum
karotte sich dann aber sehr gepflegt und
so dass diese sättigung gerade auch da
sie ist da ja freunde oder völlig ich
glaube das kommt durch dieses werde ich
das schon in mehreren etappen ist passt
wir immer zum gesagt vertrauen sei
folgende und dann ist so eine vorspeise
dann selbst schon langsam ein dann ist
so eine kleinere hauptspeise aber bis
trotzdem sage produkt insgesamt weniger
ist und die freude zum sales trotzdem da
umso mehr haben so mehr wirklich aber
den herz verstand den kernbestandteil
von vom video haben wir jetzt auch durch
die taster war unglaublich die soße war
kreativ und
ich freue mich schon was den werbedruck
das ist richtig richtig gut das kann
jetzt nur noch abgerundet werden von dem
bisher übrigens dass ein bisschen raus
aber nicht so bei helvea beste was ich
hab gedacht habe du hast ausgefallene
komplexe gerichtet ähnlich wie in der
sterneküche du kannst erst wenn er
handytaschen land verhandelt so kannte
man fühlt sich unwohl wenn leute super
league sind es ausländische schiffe und
weiß wo sich jetzt wenn ich mir diese
speise angucke denke ich habe gar keine
ahnung wie das schmecken oder so fühle
ich auch nur einfach so einen schnitt
von unseren könig mit ein bisschen
kakaopulver drauf und irgendwelchen
krems und crumble nehmen das ist
probiert
gebäude wir sind heute erwartet die
konstruierte tiramisu
also das sind so diesem sport so dieser
harten espresso kekse wir kommen sehr
kann mit dieser cafe creme schwarz und
dazu kommen diese gremien das mascarpone
das schmeckt wirklich im mund wie eine
ausgefallene ist tiramisu aber das
kloster als
service kann zu fassen können das
gericht ließ dann denkst dir was macht
der kürbis da und dann ist so dass und
alles macht sind ja der kürbis ist dass
es auch gute highlight
geisteskrank lecker
unfassbar lecker geile erfahrung bestens
da ich bin happy ich muss morgen hinter
dem organismus über 50 ist zu können
freunde ich muss jetzt erst mal an die
frische luft und sagt sagen lassen wir
sind wieder im büro und ich muss einfach
sagen es war allererste sahne ich mein
ich werde natürlich jetzt gleich meinen
gedanken noch freien lauf lassen aber
ich fühle mich gut es wurde kreativ
gekauft das wurde den frischen zutaten
gekocht der service beim 1 hört sich
einfach an eins ist klar wenn die caruso
passt aber geht um eine schnelle portion
nudeln zu essen ist dort falsch drei
vier oder fünf erschwingliche gänge
später weiß man warum und man wird froh
sein dort gewesen zu sein die gastgeber
erzeugen gekonnt eine wohlfühlatmosphäre
und obwohl dies mein erster besuch war
habe ich mich wie ein stammgast gefühlt
auf den tellern zeigen sich die
überraschend hübsche bilder an denen
sich jeder gourmet erfreuen kann
regionale und saisonale zutaten stellen
den koch vor die aufgabe einen spagat
zur italienischen küche zu schaffen was
sie mit bravour gelingt kurzgefasst
gewinnt man den seltenen eindruck dass
das gastgeber paar nicht nur ihren beruf
sondern ihre berufung gefunden hat diese
liebe zum kochen und zur
gastfreundschaft habe ich bisher nur
selten erlebt die beste pasta meines
bisherigen lebens 5 von 5 punkten
das war zum video leute ist war ein
absolutes festmotto gedanke an die
karosse pasta war für dieses essen ich
werde auf jeden fall wieder zu gast sein
wird sehen wir uns ja sogar dort macht
nächsten video